ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิคสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนโอเค
เดี๋ยวเราเขียนวันที่ก่อนแล้วกันนะคะคุณ
ได้
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์ครับค่ะวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
23 ครับเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมครับปีพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับปีคศอะไรคะที่ธอส
2022 ครับค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครู
มิตอนนี้นะครับเมืองที่คุณนิคอยู่เนี่ย
เวลา
8:00 น 51  5 นาทีค่ะ
ครับแล้วเมืองที่คุยหญิงอยู่กี่โมงแล้ว
ครับเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่ก็เหมือนเดิมนะคะ
9 เหมือนเดิมอะไรครั้งเร็วกว่าครูนิด
หนึ่งชั่วโมงเหมือนเดิมส่วน Wall  11
nagi  kicks  Off พูดไม่จบ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ไม่ก็จะเอามาก็เหมือนเดิมก็เหมือนๆกับทุก
วันถามทำไม
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้ว่าก็เหมือนเดิมเร็วกว่าครู
นิค 1 ชั่วโมงแต่พูดเหมือนเดิมแล้วก็พูด
เวลาพรุ่งนี้แล้วก็นักเรียนต้ององค์
เหมือนเดิมอะไร
แต่พูดถึงว่าเหมือนเดิมเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนนะ
ตอนเด็กๆเพื่อนคุณนี้ก็จะชอบพูดแบบนี้
เหมือนกับว่า
ถามว่ากี่โมงแล้วอ๋อก็เหมือนเมื่อวานแหละ
xxx  Tube พี่กิต
เอ้าแบบนี้เดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวโดนนะ
แต่แล้วแต่น้ำเพื่อนแกล้งครูนิคไงก็จะได้
ยินแค่ตอนแบบเด็กๆนะเพราะเหมือนกับโตขึ้น
น่ะจะไม่ค่อยมีคนพูดแบบนี้ล่ะไม่ได้หรอก
ไม่ใช่เด็กๆแล้วไงแต่ว่างดเล่นถ้าใช่เวลา
เป็นเด็กมันก็สนุกหรอกูเล็กเมื่อก่อนนะ
คือสำหรับคุณนี้ก็คิดว่าเมื่อก่อนนะในไทย
เนี่ยในกรุงเทพฯมันมีอะไรให้เด็กๆเล่น
หรือทำเยอะแบบเป็นกิจกรรมหรือทำข้างนอก
ที่ไม่ต้องอยู่บ้าน
พรุ่งนี้ก็คิดว่าตอนนี้เด็กๆหลายคน
จากอยู่กับโทรศัพท์หรือ iPad ใช่ๆกับที่
ดูอะไรในนั้นตั้งแต่เด็กๆคุณนี้คิดว่ามัน
ไม่ค่อยดีมีเท่าไหร่หรือว่าถ้าเขาจะออกไป
ข้างนอกก็คือไปเรียนเนาะใช่เรียนแบบเรียน
พิเศษอ่ะค่ะเพื่อน filter ใช่คุยได้ไปทำ
กิจกรรมได้คนนี้กับเรียนพิเศษแค่ตอนม 6
เพราะเรียนเพื่อสอบ Admission แค่นั้นเลย
ไม่ได้เรียนเสร็จเพิ่มเติมจะเด็กปัจจุบัน
นี้ก็ไม่ถึงกับปัจจุบันนะเดี๋ยว 5 ปี 10
ปีที่แล้วเด็กๆอ่ะอายุเท่าไหร่อ่ะ 5 ขวบ
ก็เรียนพิเศษแล้วนะเฮ้อสำหรับเข้าโรง
เรียนดีๆ
วิ่งได้ยินบ่หื้อฮาตั๋วคุยยังวิ่งไม่สนใจ
อะไรอยู่เลยเล่นกับเพื่อนเล่นพ่อแม่ลูก
อ่ะไปเด็ดใบไม้แล้วมาทำกับข้าวหรือไปเล่น
ดีดลูกแก้วอะไรรอกหน้าเครื่องดีใช่ไหมคะ
เพราะว่าบ้านคุณอีกแน่ไม่ได้อยู่ในตัว
เมืองแบบกลางกรุงเทพมันก็อยู่ชานเมืองที่
แบบขับรถออกไปประมาณครึ่งชั่วโมงมันก็จะ
มีเหมือนเป็นซอยที่เล่นกันได้หรือเป็นแบบ
นานเล็กๆที่มันเล่นกันได้หลายคนทำอะไร
ขึ้นหายสายบุญถึงพูดถึงลานเมื่อก่อนนะ
ครับตอนเด็กๆกับคุณนี้จะชอบมันจะมีเหมือน
กับเป็นเป็นงานเป็นงานที่เขาจัดในร้าน
กว้างแล้วนะมันก็จะมีหลัก 2 ครั้ง 3
ครั้งซื้อแล้วในงานเขามีอะไรบ้างอ่ะคะ
เวลาแบบเขาจัดครั้งหนึ่งในงานก็มีมีหลาย
อย่างนะคือ
ไม่รู้ว่าแต่คิดว่าครูหญิงอ่ะน่าจะเคยได้
ยินแล้วก็เคยไปนะคืออันเนี้ย
ในกรุงเทพฯมันจะแปลกนิดนึงเพราะว่างานอัน
นี้เรียกว่างานวัดงานวัดก็ดูอยู่ในดูสิคะ
แต่ที่กรุงเทพเนี่ยสมมติอันนี้นะอ่า
เปิดที่กรุงเทพฯมันไม่ได้เป็นนะไม่ได้
อยู่ในวัด
จะอยู่ใกล้ๆวัดไหมคะคุณอีกถามว่าใกล้ไหม
ก็ไม่ได้บางที่นะคุณนี้คิดว่าแล้วแต่ว่า
ในจุดในกรุงเทพเนี่ยมันอยู่ใกล้แค่ไหนยก
ตัวอย่างของคุณเล็กเนี่ยมันอยู่ในหมู่
บ้านที่คุณนิดอยู่แล้ววัดเนี่ยก็จะต้อง
ไม่ได้อยู่ใกล้เลยครับต้องนั่งรถไป 10
นาทีเลยนะ
ใช่แต่บางทีเนี่ยบางทีถ้าเขามีเข้าวัดเขา
มีเหมือนเป็นลานกว้างมากๆเนี่ยที่ให้คน
จัดงานวัดเนี่ยก็จะอยู่ในวัดเหมือนกันมัน
ก็คิดว่าแล้วแต่แล้วแต่ที่ที่วัดเขามี
ด้วย
ว่าไม่ว่าจะจัดที่ไหนจัดในหมู่บ้านที่มี
คนมีลานบางๆก็เรียกงานวัดเหมือนกันเนาะ
เพราะว่าคิดว่าของหรืออะไรหลายๆอย่างมัน
ก็คล้ายๆกันใช่มันก็คล้ายๆกันคิดว่าเพราะ
ว่างานนี้มันเริ่มจากอาจจะสมัยก่อนหลายๆ
ปีเนี่ยงานนี้มันอยู่แค่ในวัดค่ะใช่แล้ว
มันก็จะมีอย่างเงี้ยคือคุณนิคน่ะสำหรับคน
นี้คิดว่างานที่มันมีเหมือนเสาชิงช้าคือ
อันนี้นะ
หรือว่าหมาบ้านปุ้ยมากวิ่งได้ชิงช้า
สวรรค์นะกูดิเดี๋ยวไม่ใช่สิถูกต้องแล้ว
ชิงช้าสวรรค์ว่าเสาชิงช้าในความเป็นเดียว
ยาเอาชิงช้านั้นคือสีแดงหรือเปล่าแล้วของ
ยังไม่ใช่สนามเด็กเล่นที่เราเป็นนั่งแล้ว
ก็คืออันนี้คือชิงช้าสวรรค์ชายการๆๆเป็น
เครื่องนำไปแล้วนะใช่คุณจำผิดอันนี้
ชิงช้าสวรรค์หรือม้าหมุน
เด็กๆเหมือนโดเรม่อนเลยนะชัดปกติมาหุ่น
มันต้องเป็นมานะไม่เปิดเดี๋ยวนี้ก็เขาก็
คงเปลี่ยนน้องแล้วแต่เด็กชอบเลยค่ะก็เป็น
ตัวการ์ตูนที่เด็กชอบจริงๆนี้ก็มีม้านะ
อยู่ตรงนี้ไงอ่ะไซร้ค่ะมีมาด้วยก็แล้วแต่
ว่าอันนี้อันนี้ก็มาเหมือนกัน
ใช่มั้ยมาไม่สีม่วงๆเนี่ยเขาใช่ใช่ใช่นาน
ตอนนี้แหละเวลาคุณคิดว่าถ้าเห็นสินค้า
สวรรค์ม้าหมุนแล้วก็มีขนมมีของกินขายเยอะ
ๆเนี่ยหรือมีเครื่องเล่นแบบอย่างอื่นมัน
ก็เขียนเรียนวัดใช่ๆค่ะแค่นี้ชิงช้า
สวรรค์แล้วก็คืองานวัดแล้วค่ะเออใช่
แล้วก็เขามีกี่วรรณะปกติ
ก็บางครั้งก็มี 7 วันไหมเออเสือ 9 วันนี้
คนไทยชอบเลข 9 ไงหรือถ้าแบบมีการปกติผู้
หญิงถ้าแถวบ้านผู้หญิงนะคะก็จะแบบ 9 วัน
ก็มีบางครั้งค่ะไม่ค่อยมีหนึ่งวันสองวัน
เนี่ยไม่มีหรอกเออใช่ไม่มีเพราะคิดว่ามัน
น้อยไปอุดเขาเอาของมาตั้งแต่ว่ามีวัน
เดียวมีทำไมไปหาส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยมีหลายวัน
ถ้าใกล้บ้านโถเราเป็นงานวัดที่อยู่ใกล้
บ้านก็ไปทุกวันนะครับแต่ถ้าไม่ใกล้ก็อาจ
จะไปแบบแค่ไม่กี่คืนก็ส่วนใหญ่เขาจะตอน
กลางคืนเนาะคือคนจะไปเยอะๆค่ะตอนกลางคืน
ชายง่ายตอนกลางคืนแต่ก็คิดว่าพวกร้านหรือ
ของกินก็จะเขาก็จะมาตั้งร้านมาขายตอน
โรงเรียนแล้วนะเพราะคิดว่าสอบควันเนี่ย
แดดมันร้อนให้คนนี้ก็จะไม่ค่อยเดินเท่า
ไหร่ไอ้ใช่แต่ตอนเย็นชายตอนเย็นก็จะสนุก
แต่เธอผู้หญิงเนี่ยไปงานวัดชอบทำอะไรใน
งานวันเหรอครับโดยจริงๆก็คือชอบไปกินอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงไม่ไม่ค่อยไม่ค่อยชอบชิงช้าสวรรค์
นะมันสูงเปิดชิงช้าสวรรค์ของบ้านเรานะที่
ไทยนั้นก็น่ากลัวด้วยนะเพราะว่าเก่า
แล้วเวลาคุณนี้ก็เคยนั่งแล้วผมมันก็ขึ้น
ไปอ้ะต้องเที่ยวมันแบบมันมันแกว่งแล้วไอ้
เฮี้ยแล้วคุณเหอะมันจะหมุนแล้วไงวะ bunuh
แบบตู้ๆๆ
ลูกลูกมาหรือเปล่า
แต่ก็นั่นแหละครับก็เลยคิดว่ามันเก่าใช่
พ่อถ้าคุณอิ๊กมันจะมีอีกอย่างนึงอ่ะ
ที่แบบงานวัดมันจะมีมายากคือผู้หญิงจะชอบ
อีกอย่างหนึ่งที่ชอบตอนเด็กๆเลยนะคะนอก
จากจะไปกินเนี่ยก็คือไปดูลิเกมีไหมลิเกมี
มีๆลิเกเนี่ยเดี๋ยวเนอะคุณนี้ก็ไม่มีภาพ
ลิเกดูให้ลิเกเนี่ยดีนะสาวว่าจะไม่มีใน
งานวัดทุกงานวัดหอใช่ๆ
แต่ก็คิดว่าในไทยเนี่ยในกรุงเทพฯมันมี
น้อยมากคืองานวัดที่คนนี้เคยไปเนี่ยจะไม่
มีลิเก
ซึ่งยันว่าที่กูหญิงเคยไปเนี่ยกับเด็กๆ
เลยนะตอนนี้ไม่มีแล้วนะคะตอนนี้เหมือน
ลิเกก็ไม่ค่อยมีนะแต่เมื่อก่อนน่ะเขาก็จะ
มีมีลิเกนะแบบงานวัดอ่ะค่ะเนื้อให้ดูอัน
นี้ใช่ไหมเนี่ยคือลิเกเอ่อแต่ถ้าชายชาย
ชายหาดโคนิ
เหมือนแบบปลอด Way คนไทยนักเรียนไม่ใช่ก็
จะมีแต่งตัวแบบ
เล็กเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรระยิบระยับใช่มั้ย
เพชรบิ๊กวรรคเออใช่แบบเห็นแล้วแสบตา
เห็นแล้ว
รวยบ้างเลย
ใช่
แล้วนะครับเจ๊
ครูหญิงจะอยู่ไหมครับเนื้อเพลงค่ะโอเคผู้
หญิงเน็ตผู้หญิงครั้งหรือเปล่าใช่เมื่อ
กี้หน้าจอมันหายเกิด
ตอนนี้มาแล้วใช่ไหมคะเขาก็โอเคค่ะโอเค
S แล้วแล้วครูนิคล่ะคะถ้าแบบไปงานวัดอ่ะ
คือนิดชอบทำอะไร
คนนี้ชอบทำอะไรอ่ะ The  Mega ชอบเล่นอัน
นี้เล่นอะไรคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ก็เลยนะป่าป่ารูปดอก 3 เลขดอกคือเขาก็จะ
มีรูปดอกให้แล้วก็เดี๋ยวนะเขาจะเรียกว่า
ปลารูปดอกหรือปลาปาโป่งปาลูกโป่งหรือ
เปล่าตาโป่งก็ได้มั้ยไอ้เพราะว่ามันจะมี
รูปโป่งเนี่ยตรงนี้เราเนี่ยไอ้พวกเนี้ย
ไอ้สัตว์ชายแล้วเขาก็จะถ้าจำไม่ผิดน่าจะ
20 บาทก็จะให้มา 5 ดอกก็คือเป็นรูปต่อ
เหมือนกับเป็นมันจะมีแหลมมากและเขาก็
เกี่ยวชายมันป่าเข้าไปถ้าลูกโป่งเราก็
จะได้รางวัลแต่เขาก็ออกว่าถ้าแตก 3 ถ้า
ลูกโป่ง 3 ลูก 8 ก็จะได้รางวัลเป็นตุ๊กตา
หรือเป็นหมอดูหนังแบบนี้
ครูนิเคยเล่นปลาดอกปาลูกดอกรสปาโป่งเนี่ย
แล้วได้รางวัลไหมคะเขินคนที่ที่ที่ใหญ่ๆ
นะไม่ใช่เป็นมาม่าปากกา
รางวัลใหญ่ๆไม่เขินเออ
แต่ก็ตอนบ้างนะคุณนี้ก็คิดว่ามันต้องมี
อะไรในเนี่ยในเกมปาลูกโป่งเนี่ยเพราะว่า
บางทีอ่ะมาลูกดอกเนี่ยโดนลูกโป่งแต่มัน
ไม่แตก
เอาแต่ดอกมันมันแม่ไหนอ่ะใช่มันคมมันไม่
คมหรือเปล่า
เพราะคุณส่งครับวิ่งสุวรรณลูกโป่งมันก็ดู
มันก็ดูน่าจะแตกง่ายๆนะจัดการเป่าขนาด
นั้นน่ะเฮ้ยไม่ใช่คุณนี้ก็เลยคิดว่าเอ
หรือเขาอ่ะทำให้ลูกก็บอกแม่มันไม่คม
แล้วเขาต่อต้องเอาเงินใช่ไหมใช่ๆทำแบบทุก
คนป่าแล้วได้ตุ๊กตา
ได้หมอนได้ผ้าห่มเขาก็ไม่ได้เงินใช่ไหม 20
บาทแล้วได้ของแบบนี้มันก็ไม่โอเคนะคือ
ทั้งร้านแล้วนะคะครับแต่มันก็สนุกดีเนี่ย
คนนี้จะสู้ๆอันนี้ก็ไปงานวัดแล้วก็ของาน
วัดบางที่อันนี้ครูดีก็ไม่มีรูปเหมือนกัน
งานวัดบางที่เขาจะมีที่เรียกว่าเป็นสาว
น้อยตกน้ำคุณ
นี้จะกับครูหญิงไม่เคยไม่เคยเห็นหนาวงาน
วัดที่มีสาวน้อยตกน้ำเลยนะไม่ใช่ไม่เคย
เห็นเกินไม่เคยไปงานวัดที่มีสองร้อยตกน้ำ
เลยอ่ะคือคนนี้ก็เคยเห็นแค่ถังน้ำแต่ไม่
มีน้อย
ที่มันจะมีผู้หญิงอ่ะนั่งอยู่แล้วมันก็จะ
มีตัวเป้าตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะคือขนมปลาโดนจะมี
มันก็จะพับแล้วผู้หญิงก็จะตกลงไปในน้ำใช่
มันก็ต้องสั่งน้ำประมาณไม่ลึกมากจะอยู่
ประมาณแน่นหน้าอก
เคยเห็นฐานเห็นน้ำแต่ไม่มีสาวน้อยคิดว่า
สาวน้อยน่าจะไปเปลี่ยนชุดเพราะเปรียบ
หรือว่าสาวน้อยจะตกน้ำบ่อยแล้วก็หนาวเลย
ว่ะเออขอพันธุ์สักแป๊บนึงก่อนนะ
ใช่คืนดีก็คิดนะว่าเอ๋เราเค้าจะมีสาวน้อย
หรือผู้หญิงเนี่ยกิจคนที่ต้องมาเปลี่ยน
ถ้าลองคิดดูว่าถ้าเป็นคนเดิมเนี่ยทั้งคืน
อ่ะ
สบายนะเนี่ยมันเปียกตลอดเวลาเจอ
แล้วก็
ของกินใช่ผู้หญิงชอบไปกินอะไรถ้าเป็นงาน
วัดคุยชอบกินอันนี้กูนิคเขาเรียกว่าหอย
ทอดอ่ะค่ะเขาจะทอดเดี๋ยวลองถ้าเมียรูปไหม
หน้าได้แล้วปีหาก็ได้ค่ะพบกับกินของคุณ
นิคเนี่ยส่วนใหญ่ถ้าไปงานวัดจะกินของหวาน
ขอคุยอีกเนี่ยนะคะแบบตอนเด็กๆอ่ะเหมือน
กับ
เหมือนกับว่ามันหากินยากมั้งด้วยความให้
เราไม่ได้อยู่กรุงเจ้าอยู่ต่างจังหวัดไง
แล้วก็จะกินแต่ข้าวที่บ้านใช่ไหมคะแล้ว
แบบงานวัดอ่ะเนี่ยค่ะหอยทอดนักเรียนเออ
[เพลง]
สักครู่นะคะจริงๆคนนี้ก็ชอบแต่จะชอบแบบ
เป็นแผ่นๆแบบใหญ่ๆๆๆเหมือนอย่างอันเนี้ย
ที่นี่ใช่มั้ยเนี่ยเนี่ยๆนี่หอยอย่างนี้
ค่ะหอยทอดใช่คือว่าไม่รู้ทำไมนะหอยทอดงาน
วัดอ่ะมันอร่อยมากๆใช่ได้ตัวนี้ก็ชอบคน
นี้ก็ชอบหอยทอดก็แต่เดี๋ยวนะมันมีหอยทอด
ที่จริงไม่รู้ว่าทำไม
คู่นี้ก็เคยลองทำเองเรามันไม่เหมือนกัน
กับงานวัดอ่ะมันต้องแบบมันดูเหมือนทำง่าย
นะคะแต่มันทำยากเหมือนกันนะเออจะทำยังไง
ให้มันกลับกรอบเออแล้วก็อร่อยแบบงานวัด
ธรรมซึ่งผู้หญิงชอบมากไปงานวัดก็คือต้อง
ไปกินไปทอดแบบก็จะมีกระทะกลมๆๆใหญ่เออใช่
แล้วก็ผัด path แบบมันใหญ่มากใช่คุณนี้ก็
จะชอบไปเกมในนี่ไปก็ List กินอะไรวันนี้
ชอบกินขนมถังแตก
ใช่ฉันแต่ก็เป็นขนมอีกอย่างหนึ่งที่ว่าไป
งานวัดจะได้กินใช่งั้นมันต้องมีที่งานวัด
แล้วคือเมื่อก่อนล่ะคุณนี้ก็จะชอบไปดูเขา
ทำเพราะคิดว่าในขนมอันนี้มันเปิดแปลกมัน
ก็คุณนี้มีรูปภาพอันนั้นคือ
ถ้าเป็นแบบนี้
อันนี้อันนี้ไม่ได้อยู่ในงานวัดแต่ว่าขนม
ถังแต่แต่มันจะเป็นแบบนี้ครับขาซ้ายมันจะ
เป็นเหมือนเป็นแป้งมั้ยใช่คือตอนแรกในคุณ
ไม่รู้ว่าเอ๊ะเราก็ทำยังไงให้ตรงขอบขอบ
เนี่ยมันบางๆแล้วไข้ทางในมันเป็นนิ่มๆเขา
ทำยังไงมันเหมือนไม่มีปลอมแบบฟูๆนิดหน่อย
ตอนนั้นซึ่งแล้วพอเห็นเขาทำแล้วแบบเออมัน
น่าอร่อยเนาะแล้วมีครีมมีของหวานข้างใน
ถึงไส้เนี่ยตายสอบใจชอบตอนนี้เด็กมันน่า
จะเป็นไส้เนี้ยไส้มะพร้าวน่ะค่ะได้
มะพร้าวเนี่ยคือเป็นแบบเขาเรียกว่าอะไร
เป็นคลาสสิคเป็นเซ็ต Original ที่เนาะเลย
อย่างแรกแล้วเหมือนก็ตอนนี้เขาก็มีเขาก็
มีเหมือนนับถอยทองลูกเกดหรือข้าวโพดข้าว
พวกก็จะแทนที่คนชอบกิน
นี้
แล้วอีกอย่างครับมีขนมหวานอีกอย่างอีกกับ
มีขนมหวานที่คุณชอบกินอีกนะครับแบบในงาน
วัดเนี้ยก็จะรู้ว่าแค่ตั้งแต่ขนมเบื้อง
ขนมเบื้องคนนี้จะชอบกินไส้หวานมากูก็
เหมือนกันผู้หญิงก็ว่าไส้หวานก็จะเป็นฝอย
ทองเหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะยายใช่คือคุณก็ไม่
เข้าใจนะทำไมเขาเรียกไส้เค็มแต่เขาบอกว่า
มันเป็นไส้เค็มเพราะมันทำจากกุ้ง
อ๋อ
ดีแบบสีส้มๆ
แต่ว่าไม่ใช่มะพร้าวหรอเออมันเป็นมะพร้าว
คือคุณนี้ก็จะชอบพูดกับเพื่อนว่ากุ้งอะไร
วิญญาณกุ้งหรือเปล่าเวลากินเท่าไหร่ก็คุณ
เอาไส้เค็มล้วนมีกุ้งผู้หญิงเคยกินนะคะ
ขนมเบื้องไส้เค็มไม่มีกุ้งด้วยหรอเจอแบบ
มะพร้าวแล้วก็ไปผัดจะให้เขาบอกว่าเมื่อ
ก่อนนะมันอาจจะเป็นกุ้งฝอยอ่ะ
เรียกว่าเทมข้างอันนี้ไม่รู้ว่าจริงไหมนะ
แต่คิดว่าเพราะมันทำเป็นสีส้มด้วย
ใช่จ้านั่นแหละครับก็เลยคิดว่าเออเนี้ย
ขนมเบื้องเราก็อีกอย่างหนึ่งที่จะเห็นได้
งานไวจะเขื่อนนี้อะไรนักยูนิคอันนี้คือ
อะไรคะอันนี้คือรถก็เป็นรถแบบปลาหมึกย่าง
อ่ะเฮ้อเหนื่อยแล้วคิดเยอะปลาหมึกย่าง
เนี่ยที่คุณอีกชอบดูก็คือคนนี้จะไม่ค่อย
ซื้อนะอันนี้เป็นเป็นปลาหมึกเค้าเรียกว่า
ปลาหมึกบดใช่ไหมเพราะว่าจะมีเครื่องบดแบบ
เนี้ย
แล้วก็เอาปลาหมึกที่นั่งแล้วใส่ลงไปหรอ
ให้มันแบนๆ
มันๆแล้วมันแต่ว่าไอ้ตัวไอ้เครื่องเนี้ย
ครับข้างในมันจะทำให้ปลาหมึกมันจะเป็น
เป็นแบบเป็นเส้นๆนิดนึงอ่ะแต่มันยังไม่
ได้ขาดออกจากกันนะคือมันก็เป็นเส้นๆแล้ว
ก็ถ้าจะไปกินก็ไปฉีดเอาแล้วก็ตู้
ใช่มันก็จะกินง่ายกว่าที่แบบมันจะเป็นตัว
แบบนี้ช่วยพบปลาหมึกมันจะค่อนข้างเหนียว
มากๆอ่ะไอ้ใช่แล้วมันก็ทำให้เหมือนจับปลา
หมึกมันยาวขึ้นคนก็จะเขียนว่าเอาต้นไงใช่
แต่เนี่ยคุณนี้ก็เพราะได้งานวันนี้เขาก็
จะมีแบบนี้เป็นแถวๆใช่ไหมครับมันก็จะไม่
เหมือนกันเอาออดตามราคาต่างกันตามอะไรอ่ะ
ครับก็ตัวเล็กตัวใหญ่ก็ถ้าเราก็ราคามันก็
จะถูกก็จะอยู่ข้างล่างค่ะอ๋อเค็มไปหน่อย
ก็จะแพงขึ้นไปชายตัวของมันเป็นกว่าระดับ
ซะที่
แต่ถ้าเกิดว่ามีเงินนิดเดียวก็กินระดับ
นี้นะ
เหมือนเดี๋ยวข้าดับ 3 นิสัยไม่ค่อยดีนะคะ
เพราะว่า
ครับเออใจตอนนี้ก็เป็นของกินอีกอย่างนึง
ที่อยู่คู่กับงานวัดเหมือนกันนะคะปลาหมึก
บดเนี่ยง่ายที่จะมีหลายอย่างและของกินบาง
ที่ก็จะมีเหมือนเป็นลูกชิ้นปิ้งค่ะใช่ๆ
จังมีครั้งใหญ่ๆได้ก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนี่ยอาหาร
ที่เป็นอาหารจานเดียวน้องกินง่ายๆๆไง
เหมือนขนมจีนก็มีนะที่ขนมจีนขึ้นอยู่กับ
เขาเรียกว่าอะไรเป็นผักแบบบุฟเฟ่ต์ที่คิด
หน่อยตลอด
ใส่สายแล้วก็แบบจริงก็ยังมีอะไรให้เล่น
อีกเยอะมากๆมันสนุกน่ะค่ะถ้าเราเป็นเด็ก
อ่ะเราอยากไปทุกวันเฮ้ยแต่แม่เราเนี่ยพ่อ
แม่เราก็ไม่อยากให้ไปแต่ว่าเสียเงินเยอะ
ไปเปลืองเงินอันนี้ก็อยากเล่นอันนี้ก็
อยากกินว่าทุกอย่างที่เล่นคือไม่ได้ฟรีนะ
คะต้องจ่ายเงินใส่เงินแต่มันก็สนุกเนาะ
สมัยก่อนคิดว่าตอนนี้มันไม่ค่อยมีเราไหม
ในกรุงเทพฯต้องแบบผู้หญิงเคยเห็นก็คือ
ต้องออกนอกไปข้างนอกกรุงแบบเหมือน
กรุงเทพฯข้างนอกหน่อยอ่ะค่ะ
แบบที่มีวัดแล้วก็ยังมีเหมือนชุมชนเป็น
บ้านของคนอยู่อย่างเนี้ยเขาก็จะมีงานวัด
แต่ถ้าในเมืองในไม่ค่อยมีไม่มีเพราะมัน
ต้องใช้พื้นที่ฉันหรือว่าก็จะมีตรงช่วง
ส่งปลานะคะคุณนี้ก็จะมีแต่ไม่มีอาหารไม่
มีทั้งสวรรค์ไม่พี่ปาลูกโป่งอ่ะไม่มี
ใช่ๆมากับตอนนี้ก็จะจะแน่นแค่ของกินมาก
กว่าสายค่ะเจาะเลือดเตือนพรุ่งนี้ก็พานัก
เรียนไปเที่ยวงานวัดมางานวัดสนุกก็นั่น
เองเคยไปมาบอกให้ฟังหรือชอบเบนซ์เดี๋ยวจะ
ไปอ่านกายค่ะแต่ว่าวีดีโอดีหมดเวลาแล้ว
เนาะเดี๋ยวคุยกับคนนี้ก็ขอไปเที่ยวงานวัด
ก่อนนะคะไปแล้วนะใช่ไปหาของกินนะ
เดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
ครับอ่ะ